welcome to this video playing hypnotic
specter from the US and he's gotten
insanely high rating what the heck did
he do I has always been decent but very
high queen bee six is a strange move why
would you go queen bee six hmm whatever
and how to how to play though very
strange I'd like to play C 3 and d 4 of
course okay and that's so let's prepare
that default takes takes my tags hmm not
sure that this it looks it looks weird
come on you cannot play this like in
like an old lady if he is playing knight
c6 and then be six that this stuff could
be six I mean need to be aggressive okay
guys taking the poly now Queen to rook t
193 this is the idea to go to get on d6
yeah certainly I'm compensation but so
not clear that white has got more than
that
yet the sky stretching is insanely high
is his playing on the ICC for ages never
seen him frightened I redditor that home
okay and yeah he's covering be five
square I still got very nice fluent
development question is how to continue
queen bee 60 this Bishop e3 and 94 as a
possible way forward mmm how's the stock
slice for what I mean this doesn't
surprise me I don't really believe in
his his opening but really nice okay
anyway III what is he doing queen bee
three
Bishop t to maybe be shoved into we
should be too intending 95 I can take on
be too maybe
that's now it's possible Bishop f4 our
Bishop f4 is a good move yeah come on
let's let's play this the ideas Bishop
t6 after a five I can do Bishop e3 and
he just has caused his bishop okay he
can take on see three hours and it's it
and probably cannot take I mean hard to
believe yeah this actually looks
terrible for black
shepton bishop t6 how do you prevent
that if ifs is really really hungry
do I go to g6 yeah it's it's it's got
Bishop t6 this is the idea
yeah i can probably now there's more
than one good good way forward
yeah come on I cannot spend all day him
should I go or if five is also good come
on e5 just opening the long diagonal
it's got a hard time to to continue
if he takes a five is Bishop c7 9006
wins the Queen doesn't this win the
Queen
yep Queenie 896 they get sides the Queen
for just a minor piece it's not even two
pieces on or anything
hmm yeah that's it
yeah he lost much time in the opening
continuing
yeah it's really a queen I'm playing the
slight layer slightly inaccurate yeah
well whatever
yeah come on let's let's open this up
here it's probably easier exchange some
stuff and reduce any wake complexity and
the position just building queen p 7 or
quincy 7 coming
check I will be five this Queen yet
check
check-check time warning huh check check
black resilience okay okay and let's
let's check this opening briefly as what
was interesting yeah I don't really
understand why you play Queen b61 but ok
so I'm just trying to open up quickly
getting at his dark squares if you play
slowly it's probably not too bad the
screen b6 stuff so I grabbed this pawn
yeah now here and now it's it's it's
it's tricky and that this looks normal
maybe a 6mm know maybe you should castle
make sure that you actually manage to
cancel this already had the computer
already is is giving giving a wider a
very very big edge now here create three
is very strong and tending 94 okay okay
I'm not a comp castles but this is also
big edge the only move for black novice
knight c6 according to computer to even
continue and this is flat out flat out
winning yeah this okay wins the queen
but he really didn't have a great move
anymore 96 you must play giving up the
exchange okay and that's really just the
exchange for nothing it's got a porn but
look at this this is the problem you can
even
yeah well 94s not a threat yeah blackest
acid rock t6 even as possible yeah just
lost too far too much time in the
opening with queen bee 66 g sixes just
just very risky and okay it was playable
he only needs to play castles now and
then it's it's unclear maybe yeah thanks
for watching